welcome back to my round six recap from
carguro chess before I forget we do have
a merch promotion going uh maybe the
title of this video will will
incentivize some people to get oh no my
queen merch so anyway let's get to recap
in this game I played a Christian Moen
or Ole Christian Moen older player from
Norway I think he might actually be one
of the oldest players in the section I
looked at this feed a profile he was
born in 1951 and the majority of my
opinions tournament have been much
younger than me I think I've only played
two older players thus far out of six
rounds so I decided before the game
pairings went up right after my my
previous round round five is a such a
marathon game so uh pairing went up
maybe like 45 minutes before and I
didn't really have much time to prepare
uh but beforehand I decided that if I
had the chance
I would go into
a Stafford gamut and I was ready if he
took the pawn
I was gonna play Knight C6
but he didn't take the pawn he played
Knight to C3 it's been on my bucket list
for a while to play Stafford Gambit in
an over the board b-day
classical tournaments but it'll have to
wait
um I was excited too I was kind of
jittery before they came but he played
Knight C3 and I was actually debating
whether to play Bishop C5 here and still
try and transpose into his Stafford but
the drawback of Bishop C5 takes Knight
C6 is white just has more options Knight
F3 is a very good line Knight D3 also
gives white some edge of course this is
also like plus two according to the
engine so even going into staff again it
would have been a bit risky but
um I I wanted to make the gamble that he
he's not the type of person who who
binges my um Stafford content on on
YouTube
so anyway uh no staff for this game
instead we had a four nights after
Bishop B5 Bishop B4 this is a copycat
variation not sure if it's officially
the copycat variation
um maybe it's just symmetrical variation
but I'm copying him so far and the main
move I
um I'm prepared for normally is D3 after
which I would play D6 and if light
develops uh I was planning to play 97
and go into this line it's a variation
I've studied in the past but instead of
uh playing Pawn D3 here he went for a
more direct move Knight to D5 and this
is a move that I actually looked at
before the game because I saw that he
played a game maybe about 15 years ago
that featured Knight D5 in this position
so before the game I had briefly
prepared what happens of Knight T5 here
now with casting included it's a little
bit different but I was still able to
use the same idea in my pregame
preparation I went ahead and took the
knights after takes I don't move the
nylon C6 but I play the move Pawn E4 a
nice counter attack and after he takes
on C6 I don't take the Knight but I take
on C6 hitting the bishop and it's a cool
idea
um kind of a fancy way of trading a lot
of things but Bach is guaranteed to win
back on the minor piece and I thought
that at the very least it's equal maybe
there's a small Edge for black as we'll
see so he plays Bishop E2 I take the
Knight he takes and then I play Bishop
to C5 a bishop really no longer serving
a purpose on B4 and I played Bishop T5
uh maybe for a couple reasons first of
all of course I want to allow with the
King but I'm also preventing a pawn to
D4 and then an interesting sequence of
moves happens because he plays C3
preparing D4 and I prevent it with Queen
to D3
and at this point I was remembering some
famous morphe game
uh it's like one of the most famous
morphe games where he plays Queen D3
also from a four nights opening and then
later in the game I think he sacks the
queen somehow so I was feeling really
inspired especially wearing my oh no my
queen merch I'll link below but
unfortunately white is able to chase
away the queen very quickly with Bishop
to E2 which I anticipated I played Queen
G6 and white gets in D4 and here are my
Bishops attacked but um it's a common
theme in this game when my pieces are
attacked I don't always move them right
away here I go for a counter attack
Bishop H3 uh threatening mates and he
defends Bishop F3 and now I move back to
D6 and I was feeling good here even
though it's pretty close to equal
um white has a little bit of development
to do this bishop doesn't have a great
Square because I'm covering F4 and G5
and I have some nice kingside pressure
as well so he plays rookie one I
challenge the rook and then he plays
Rook to E3 interesting move maybe trying
to get my Bishop to move away and I do
just that Bishop E6 then he plays Bishop
D2 yeah I was trying to just make sense
of like the plan in this position it's
really close to symmetrical white does
control a little bit more space but I
have
more harmonious development with the
Bishops and I opted for natural looking
plan to try and double up Rooks on the
e-file
and this is a very important thing to
understand in the middle game in this
case there is one fully open file so
it's my plan to just double the books
and try and fight for that file
uh he responds with Bishop H5 which
surprised me a little bit because I
wasn't quite
sure what the bishop is doing on H5
after I play Queen F5 but then he plays
H3 and now it's clear he wants to just
harass my queen and maybe try and induce
some trades I went ahead and played Rook
88 he plays Bishop to G4
and here I took a bit of a think because
there are some options where to move the
queen and this is a bit of an
embarrassing moment for me because I
made a very bad mistake on the next move
I took so long just making sure or
supposedly like thinking that the
tactics are okay for me but um just
completely overlooking White's response
the move I played was Queen F4
and I thought this is okay because I
have all this pressure on the king side
threatening Queen H2 I was mainly
calculating Pawn G3 and what happens
after Bishop takes G4 in these lines
um before we get to why Queen F4 is a
bad move what I should have done and
like I I was very close to doing is
playing Queen B5 just kind of keeping
pressure
I didn't go for this line because I
wasn't sure if I had much of an edge
after takes takes Queen C2 and maybe
it's just close to equal only so much I
can do here is back
but Queen F4 was just a horrendous move
and he played his next move really
quickly
Rook to E5
and then I realized
oh no my queen
it's attacked by the bishop he cut off
the battery
so I no longer have Queen H2 the only
safe Square to move the Queens at six
actually there's a couple options here
that we'll get to but Queen F6 runs into
Bishop G5 Queen G6 Bishop
H5
and the queen is trapped here all the
squares are covered lights Bishops are
actually very dominant here so
um
I realized after rookie five I'm I'm in
trouble when I had overlooked when I
played Queen F4 I thought I could just
take on G4 and I was calculating Queen's
X G4 and like we would trade
actually Queen takes G4 there's just
Queen takes D2 I don't know what I was
thinking uh essentially what I missed
was H takes G4 and my queen is still
stuck like if I move back to F6 here
Bishop G5 and there's a really
unfortunate line because it looks like
black might be holding on with Queen G6
but then after it takes if I take the
Rook white takes back and opens the D
file and I can't take the bishop because
I got mated and once I saw this I was
really sad and I came
to the conclusion that in this position
I have to give away my queen and the
only way to fight is okay first to take
on G4 after H takes G4 to take the Rook
and fortunately even though I blundered
it's not completely losing yet because
after takes takes
I am down the queen
I missed her a lot especially a few
moves ago I I thought I was playing for
some Advantage
um but I have rook and Bishop uh for
Queens so White's only up a little bit
of material if we do like the point
value it's eight points versus nine
points but I I thought this this
position it's going to be not easy to
defend because white can kind of grind
down for a while he starts with Pawn G3
hitting the bishop I move back
and then here I was really scared of
this move Queen to B3 I really wasn't
sure what I was going to do after this
move
um he didn't end up playing it he played
King to F1 but after Queen B3
my pawns attacked
and if I move it then there's Queen A4
attacking two undefended pawns if I play
Pawn B5 he would have A4 and like things
are opening up and generally in a
position like this I just want to try
and be solid and not induce even more
weaknesses in my position
so I think Queen B3 was a better option
but after it came to B1 or up came to F1
then I had time to just try and
consolidate I played Pawn C5 just
attempting to trade off the pawns I
actually set up a small trap here too if
he didn't go into he played D5 but the
Trap is if he takes and then plays Queen
D5 it looks like white spinning a pawn
but I was gonna play Bishop B6 and if
white takes the pawn I have Rook to E2
and then it's actually a really nice
counter play for black in this position
but after Pawn D5 uh things close down a
little bit I play rookie 4. he plays B3
maybe preparing C4 I play B6 Queen F3
and G6
at this point I realized I just wanna
be super solid and and basically make a
fortress like everything in my position
is defended I guess with exception of
the a pawn like I can always play A5 if
necessary and
um we played a few more moves Rook D1
team G7 G5 looks a little bit scary
because my dark squares seem vulnerable
but I do have the darks for Bishops so
there's really no concern I played Rook
E5 here hitting the pawn
and then he plays Queen to G4 if he
plays Queen F6 I just move back and uh
then actually I'm threatening Rook F5 so
it would be funny if White's also
gets the queen shot in this case black
would be winning but uh he plays Queen
G4
I play rookie for
he plays back to F3 and then he makes
eye contact but he didn't say anything
he just looked at me and I moved back he
moved back and he looked at me again I
wasn't sure if he's like repeating
trying to fake me out
um and then after rookie four I thought
maybe he's gonna go for Queen H3 but
then he moved back or no wait no there
is um uh a dgt error
in the broadcast some people in the
leeches chat were confused uh he did not
play King G1 I believe we just agreed to
a draw here like I played rookie four
and then I think he offered me a draw on
his turn my mind is kind of hazy right
now but uh we did agree to withdraw and
uh yeah I don't know why that broadcast
said white played King G1 that
definitely did not happen anyway yeah
that was my round six game I'm fortunate
to
come out alive and draw this
I've had two games today
in which I was much worse in the
previous game I was like that losing in
multiple moments this game I made a
terrible tactical blunder on very
fortunate uh to survive I think the big
issue in this game was I was just
mentally fatigued I don't like to make
excuses but when I look at the board my
mind was not turning the gears the way
it's supposed to be but it's still nice
to not lose
and um
yeah what more to say I I would have
liked to play a Stafford but it will
have to wait at least when it comes to
classical over the board chess
so uh that does it for this recap I hope
you enjoyed if you have questions leave
them below I do appreciate all the
really nice feedback and comments from
people
um hope you guys are are enjoying the
Recaps stay tuned for more there are
three more rounds I'm three and a half
out of six so stolen plus score uh no
chances for
a GM Norm I don't think but uh
definitely chances to play more
interesting hopefully entertaining chess
so stay tuned and I'll see you guys soon